look at that that's it
it's a fire
sauce dripping and all that stuff that
we invited but the sauce don't drip a
little bit
[Music]
i eat a chopped cheese literally every
day even on a day off if i don't have
one i crave it for new yorkers is a
comfort food it's going to remind you of
your childhood when you take a bite
a chopped cheese is a cheeseburger
chopped up on a roll with lettuce tomato
mayo ketchup hot sauce that first bite
into a chopped cheese is
everything
all of the flavors mixed together the
sauces the hot sauce the mayo the
ketchup the cheese with the burger meat
the crunch of the bread and the softness
of it you're mad when it ends because
you want another one
my name is jeremy i'm the owner of
bodega truck we do uh specialty chopped
cheese
i've always heard the same story it was
originated in harlem in a store called
hajjis
when i had my first chopped cheese i
thought this is amazing this cannot be
just a bodega thing it has to be sold
everywhere
every day is different on a food truck
you're never to have the same day that's
one thing that i love about having a
food truck i can go visit other
neighborhoods and reach other audiences
and other people
instead of having everybody come to me i
can make it easier and go to the people
i grew up right here in new york city in
the bronx my mom had a bodega when i was
in middle school i would go there after
school do my homework just hang out
there i would move cases of soda or
restock some things here and there i ate
a lot of sandwiches when i was younger
we would always get a chopped cheese or
a ham and cheese it was just bodega food
most of the time
i draw a lot of my inspiration from my
childhood and my mother's bodega and
just the community that i remember as a
young kid that i grew up in
it's me paying a tribute to a part of
new york that isn't around anymore
growing up bodega was more like a safe
haven for you you know you can always
hang out at the bodega you're not gonna
get in trouble there you're gonna be
looked after your bodega owners he knows
your mother or your father and if he
sees you doing something wrong they're
gonna you know put you in your place you
know that's your favorite bodega when
you walk in there and they either know
what you want they know your name you
just say the usual and they you know
they know you personally that that's to
me that's a great bodega
bold agriculture has definitely changed
modern day bodegas nowadays it's just
you're in you're out you get what you
need you go
i'm trying to keep the culture alive i'm
really trying to keep the nostalgic
involved there and people who don't
remember or who weren't around for that
i want them to see the bodega truck and
say wow this is really how it was back
in the day
[Music]
starting the bodega truck i've learned
that
food trucks is very very hard
angela is my girlfriend my right hand my
everything i'm the idea i'm the cook i'm
the chef but she is the everything else
behind the scene without her there
wouldn't be a bodega truck she's an
amazing person an amazing girlfriend and
an amazing business partner
[Music]
the sandwich kings of new york
anthony and sons panini shop that's one
of my favorite places in brooklyn i
bumped into sabino and ever since then
we've been really good friends so i'll
just order y'all i just want chopped
cheese you're making
burger cheese less tomato mayo ketchup
hot sauce the original that's original
how it goes yeah and that's why i call
it the og on my menu he's helped me out
with a lot of things regarding business
and the truck and he knew
about what i wanted to create for a long
time so he said hey why don't you test
out one of your chopped cheeses on our
menu i started eating chopped cheese
later on like 15 16 years old like once
i started getting out there because
really it was like a big thing in harlem
in the bronx you know it wasn't too much
in brooklyn i really didn't see it like
that you know that's why we put it on
the menu and because i want to get your
co-sign you know i would make sure i was
good before i posted it yeah yeah why is
this brooklyn guy making chopped jesus
yeah and i'm not gonna lie some people
when we post on social media they're
like this better be 5 hours
drives me crazy even in the city you pay
two dollars for a bottle of water yeah
they used to be what 50 cents or a
dollar yo dad we gotta raise the prices
of the bottles of water
can't charge a dollar anymore yeah
you want the typical chopped cheese
always the regular chopped cheese you
got a kit and whatever she wants
whatever she wants what i'm gonna do for
you hi i think i'm gonna do a philly
cheese thing philly cheesesteak i'm a
philly cheesesteak what's wrong with you
the philly cheesesteak and the chopped
cheese are two totally completely
different things look how fire mine is
and look how plain jane you're looking
philly cheesesteak it's a philly
cheesesteak everybody knows what it is
but a chopped cheese is different meats
different cheeses different condiments
let's switch let's see you're gonna take
a bite of this and you're gonna tell me
that
that this is better than that i mean i'm
just saying it's better
i mean it's good
it's good
but it's not bad i wonder if they have
chopped cheese in front though i doubt
it i doubt it because we have the
phillies here in the bodegas so maybe we
could bring it to philly and see if
people start gravitating towards let's
go around and ask people if they've ever
had a chopped cheese i'm trying to push
it to go to
la florida philly i'm trying to get it
to be known all over the place more
people need to know that a chopped
cheese is better than a philly and
philly could get mad at me for that
it's all good
i do six variations of chopped cheeses
the hot chick is buffalo chicken chopped
cheese with mozzarella i throw a little
blue cheese crumble on there and we use
ranch and celery bits the dominicano is
a chopped cheese with fried cheese fried
salami and ketchup mayo cabbage the
download block is a chopped cheese with
mozzarella thick cut bacon sweet and
spicy barbecue sauce and beard battered
onion rings
the down the block i also do with
chicken and that was made up by accident
on my first day somebody ordered the
download block and things were going so
fast i accidentally put chicken instead
of the burger patty
a chopped cheese is comfort food for
people you can have it for lunch you can
have it for dinner you can have it for a
late night snack you can have it after
the club is you can have it whenever and
it's always going to be good
when i was younger my mother had a
bodega so i tried to bring the same same
vibe yeah
you don't see you know i mean old school
bodegas
gotta have the quarter orders bro that's
fine appreciate that chat
that's my that's the manager right there
bruh noble dig is complete without a cat
so i have the cat chilling he's watching
over the place his name is manny's manny
the manager he he just hangs out and
watches over the place for me got on
this menu i got all the ogs six
different ways however you want it let
me get the og
i think it's a sandwich that you gotta
be from new york to be familiar with
cause anywhere else our goals like they
don't they won't even know what you're
talking about you gotta explain it's
like a burger you chop it up i feel like
that's a staple hood challenge late
night ain't nothing going on anywhere
close a good nightcap it's an art to the
vacant of the chapel
that whole culture is done it's the old
new york wayne store's word like all
that's changing it's like me and my
cousin like the bodega was so good to us
like
i would be broke and i could get credit
cause he knew me knew my mother with my
family like the people still knew us
so i would write down
what i owe and i'll be like yo probably
thursday i'm gonna come back i owe you
eight dollars for only twelve dollars
give me the sandwich give me a drink
they fed me growing up like you know
what i mean like if my mother wasn't
cooking
my mouth was working i had to go to the
store you know man they did me right for
years so
i always got love for bodegas it's lit
what what i owe you
it's on me it's all you oh lord
got the og you gotta tell me about that
credit
it's that credit that's credit here all
day you already know
that means a lot to me you got it bro
you like the way the chopsticks is going
nationwide trying to i'm trying to bring
it to
everywhere i think it's a dope idea to
definitely um
make it a global thing right philly
cheesesteaks everywhere you know what i
mean so why wouldn't the chopped cheese
be everywhere chop cheese it's a new
yorkshire that's why
you won't
exactly that and that's what i'm trying
to do i'm trying to make everybody know
about it
trying to be on the same path the
pedestal yeah
all right
just want to welcome all of y'all say hi
y'all look beautiful
y'all think y'all look beautiful bronx
native is a shop here in the bronx and
it is a shop that is proud of the bronx
and they rep it very hard when i say
south yeah
bronx native shop one of the inspiration
for his concept was a bodega and for me
it's kind of like a lighthouse it's like
a pillar in in all communities here in
new york city pairing with bronx native
for the events he throws it was a
perfect match he wants to bring the
community together and bodegas bring
communities together so bodega truck
bronx native it just worked together so
well shout out to bodega truck out here
with the best chopped cheeses in the
building in the city in the world if
you're from new york city and you know
you're from the bronx you definitely eat
chopped cheeses you know what i mean at
least once a week
i ordered the classic the og
there you go
when you know the background story when
you know the people that are making it
the hands that are making it
it does hit different you know what i
mean it hits
not only the belly but it hits the heart
too you know bronx native and the bodega
truck are preserving that bodega culture
the characteristic of what a bodega is
and bringing that in a new light in a
new way
[Music]
there's people who've actually grown up
in new york and never had a chopped
cheese and come to the truck and it's
like i can't believe i've lived my life
without this for so long
i love the popularity that is growing
the attention that it's getting i love
that uh people are taking it and
remixing it for their own chop cheese
dumplings chopped cheese empanadas i
want chop cheese to be a well-known
thing
i would want to turn one truck into a
location and then i would love to branch
out to other states i would love to go
to california i would love to go to
florida i would love to make chopped
cheese kind of like a worldwide known
thing
love what you do and you'll never work a
day in your life
[Music]
can i get